new polls show public support for the
wall growing during this government
shutdown how will those new numbers
affect Democrats strategy then a future
also-ran announces his bid for the 2020
Democrat presidential nomination Julian
Castro the leftist media celebrates the
child abuse of a new drag kid and
finally do conservatives talk too much
about the Constitution I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
so much to get to today but first before
we get to any of it we need to thank
ring our wonderful sponsor rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer today
over a million people use the amazing
ring video doorbell to help protect
their homes I love ring so much that I
have now given ring to friends of mine
and you'll know like all your cool hip
friends have it because it really works
it's phenomenal ring nose home security
begins at the front door but it doesn't
end there so now they're extending the
same level of security to the rest of
your home with the ring floodlight cam
just like the amazing ring doorbell
flood light camera is a motion-activated
camera and floodlight that connects
right to your phone with HD video and
two-way audio it lets you know the
moment anyone steps onto your property
you've probably encountered this when
you are trying to burglarize someone's
home you step on their property the
light goes on you you run away you can
see and speak to visitors you can even
set an alarm right from your phone with
rings floodlight cam when things go bump
in the night you will immediately know
what it is whether you're home or away
you could be inside you could be at the
office you could be on a beach in Puerto
Rico like Bob Menendez you the ring
floodlight camera will let you keep an
eye on your home from anywhere save up
to 150 bucks off a ring of security kit
when you go to ring calm / Knolls KO
wles
ring calm / Knolls KO wles what is it
ring calm / NOLs KN o WL e s just like
Beyonce house this government shutdown
going for you is it ok are you surviving
are you all making it through this awful
terrible yes you are statistically you
are making it through the government
shutdown and great new news for the for
conservatives and people who want to
build the wall coming out of this
shutdown you probably missed it because
all of the headlines right now are
talking about how increasingly people
blame President Trump for the shutdown
they blame president from for the
shutdown / Democrats this should come as
no surprise President Trump took credit
for the shutdown he was in a meeting
with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and
he said yep I'll own the shutdown I
would be proud to shut down the
government for border security so all
the headlines saying this is really bad
for Trump he's being blamed for the
shutdown he should end this shutdown
soon whenever the Washington Post is
telling you to do something it is a safe
bet to do
the opposite and that's what we're
seeing here because the hidden number
other than who they're blaming for the
shutdown blah blah blah is Washington
Post is showing this during the
government shutdown support for building
the wall is increasing right now support
for building the wall is up 42% is the
number of Americans who support it
that's up from 34% last January
now 54% still oppose building the wall
but that's down from 63% last January so
it doesn't matter where the people are
it matters where the momentum is headed
if the momentum is headed in the
direction of border security and
building the wall that's a bad sign for
Democrats and actually the numbers are
even better when you look at registered
voters so among registered voters
support for the wall is 46% that's four
percentage points higher than among the
population broadly now also nearly half
of those polled of wall opponents
believe that Democrats should compromise
to end the shutdown so all of this taken
together the bad news for Trump is they
blame him for the shutdown but the bad
news for Democrats is their position is
weakening so according to wopo ABC CNN
Americans blame Trump for the shutdown
but people don't care about the shutdown
there was this poll that was taken a
couple weeks ago week and a half ago by
Rasmussen which showed that 6% of
Americans said that they had been
seriously affected by the government
shutdown 21% of Americans didn't know
that the government was shut down that's
two weeks into the shutdown already one
of the longest in history now it is the
longest in history people don't really
seem to care about it but the problem
for Democrats is not even the PR it's
not the PR of the shutdown so much
speaking of PR Democrats right now are
sunning themselves down in Puerto Rico
if you've just eaten or you have a weak
stomach do not close your eyes right now
when we put up this photo Senator Bob
Menendez was photographed on a beach in
Puerto Rico shirtless gawking at some
woman's bikini right in front of her he
just looks like he's lost in this cloud
of oh this woman and Bob Menendez this
is a bad look for him because federal
investigators are fairly confident that
he paid underage prostitutes in the
Dominican
Republic so now he's in Puerto Rico he's
sort of right next door really bad look
but that's where they are they're down
there sunning themselves in Puerto Rico
yuck I'm very glad I didn't have
breakfast before today's show the reason
it's not a PR problem because they're
not going to be blamed for the shutdown
even if it shows the government's
shutdown they should be in Washington
trying to have make a compromise and
they're there sunning themselves on the
beach that's not the issue the issue for
them is more tactical when it comes to
the policy because while they're sipping
their mai tais and Bob Menendez is
gawking at young bikini clad women the
numbers are moving in the direction of
building the wall what you know we know
already the vast majority of Americans
support ending illegal immigration they
support border security actually it's
even bigger than that the majority of
Americans support reducing legal
immigration from its current rate of 1.2
million people per year down to about
half a million people per year that's
more than a 50% reduction even in legal
immigration
so this immigration issue has always
been a huge winner for Republicans and
for President Trump that's why President
Trump staked his president his
presidential campaign on building a wall
and on border security now even when
they pulled Democrats a year ago they
pulled them on whether giving amnesty to
dreamers the daca people illegal aliens
who came to the United States below the
age of 18 if that should be a priority
for a Democrat Congress even the
majority of Democrats said no that
shouldn't be the priority people care
about other issues and so the illegal
immigration has always been a big winner
reducing legal immigration now seems to
be a real winner but until recently
building the wall was a loser issue for
Republicans what does this mean it means
that you know the American people
contain multitudes and maybe they're
confused about public policy but well
Democrats have been sunning themselves
in Puerto Rico those numbers have moved
and they're not moving in a good
direction for Democrats so right now the
American people I think are also
realizing how much government they won't
miss Democrats were hoping they were
praying that if the shutdown dragged on
now to the longest in history people
would say gosh we need our IRS oh I miss
my IRS oh please bring me back my IRA
they would say they would miss all of
this government
the country is going just fine without
all of the non-essential government
workers now it can't go on forever but
it could go on for a pretty long time as
Ronald Reagan said you'll be surprised
at how much government you'll never miss
so I hope the Democrats stay in Puerto
Rico I hope Bob Menendez has the time of
his life that poor girl she has she's in
my thoughts and prayers the smart
Democrats know that it benefits them to
end this shutdown and you can see mika
brzezinski trying to turn up the
pressure on MSNBC I would take it a step
further and worry that we look weak and
that this is the moment that anybody
with ill will has to act or to get
further than they have been able to get
in the past as opposed as it pertains to
us on the international stage so Mika
now she's not using the talking points
that appeal to Democrats she's not using
oh the poor illegal aliens oh the
federal workers she doesn't use those
talking points the talking point she's
using here are we look weak our enemies
are going to attack us we're gonna be
physically harmed she's using talking
points that appeal to Republicans and
then appeal to President Trump and then
appeal to president Trump's base that
she has to do this because they're
trying to turn up the pressure on
President Trump make it feel as though
his own people are cracking his own
Republican caucuses are cracking on this
issue it doesn't seem that they are a
couple little sounds in the Senate
Lindsey Graham once president Trump both
to invoke a national emergency to build
the wall and to end the shutdown there
are some little fissures but not a lot
and it's because as it pertains to
public policy Republicans are winning
this as it pertains to image president
Trump is taking the hits sure but he has
made a whole career out of taking the
hits there's no such thing as bad press
to President Trump and so he's taking a
personal popularity hit that will
recover people's memories in this news
cycle in this 24/7 2019 news cycle are
so short it doesn't matter the old
conventional wisdom was you would have
to pay for a government shutdown at the
ballot box the old conventional wisdom
was regardless of who started it
Republicans get blamed for government
shutdowns and they lose elections
because of it
we found out that wasn't true in 2014 in
2013 Republicans shut down the
government Ted Cruz shut down the
government in 2014 Republicans took the
Senate it doesn't really matter anymore
if politics has changed since the 90s or
the 80s or whatever it doesn't really
matter so I think it's really shrewd if
the White House let Trump take the
personal popularity hit let the policy
gain in popularity and we'll end up in a
place where already you're seeing
certain Democrats saying well maybe we
could have some border security well
Chuck Schumer used to support the wall
he voted for the wall it's only getting
better and time is still on our side you
you can't wait forever on this
government shutdown but the Republicans
still do have time on our side so I they
should hold firm and if it means
invoking a national emergency finally to
break it fine but I see much more
pressure right now on Democrats than I
do on Republicans they're also the
Democrats you'll notice are also eager
to change the subject from the shutdown
so they thought for a while they were
focusing on it before Christmas you
remember was all about the shutdown this
is going to be our big talking point the
Trump shutdown they called it in the
Oval Office and then it didn't when it
didn't matter so much when it wasn't a
matter of you know really moving poll
numbers on approval ratings all of a
sudden they start talking about other
things here's brian Stelter wondering if
we're not talking enough about Russian
collusion I was watching Good Morning
America this weekend and both mornings
they led with snowstorms and scares at
malls and other stories and not this and
I just keep wondering if if the public
is ill-served if we don't make it really
clear what the stakes of this story are
how how can a mortgage for not lead with
this drama I guess is what I'm saying I
think I think plenty of times we lead
with it with this drama and we lead also
with what is becoming the looming
question over all of this and even Fox
reporters are now asking this question
of some of their sources are we think
we're just have you even heard of
Russian collusion I don't even hurt of
it I wish the mainstream media would
cover who is Bob Muller I mean what are
you saying mate president Trump and
Russia I don't know I've got to look
more into this we will talk about
much more cuz obviously a ridiculous
pivot but a necessary one for Democrats
but first let's talk a little bit about
selectquote oh yeah baby a new sponsor
and a terrific sponsor if you're like me
then you need to protect the ones you
love with life insurance especially if
you live a wild life as I do life
insurance can pay off a mortgage you can
help send kids to college it's peace of
mind if you think you can't afford it
chances are selectquote can help you get
it for less than a dollar a day and it's
really important you don't want to
without going too much into it
you know myself other family members
have been left in the lurch because
people didn't have life insurance
policies it's really the responsible
thing to do and adults should just have
it that's why you know the older you get
the more it costs that's why you should
lock in for a rate for up to ten or
twenty years now when you're younger it
makes a whole lot of sense
selectquote comparison shops up to ten
highly rated companies including
Prudential banner life and Mutual of
Omaha and others helps you find the best
rates
selectquote could find a 35 year old man
a half million dollar policy for less
than 19 bucks a month or a 37 year old
female a 3/4 of a million dollar policy
for under 22 bucks a month it is a no
brainer less than a dollar a day far
less than a cup of coffee it this is
really important I I actually hadn't
bought life insurance for a long time
I'm really glad I did it just gives you
peace of mind and you don't you don't
want to leave your family and loved ones
in the lurch I'm very very pleased that
I have life insurance and you should too
let's say let's electric would save you
time and money get your free quote at
select quote comm slash Knowles kano
wles select quote comm slash Knowles Keo
wles for your free quote don't put off
protecting your family another day
select quote comm slash Knowles get full
details on the example policy it
selectquote dot-com / commercials your
premium could vary depending on your
health issue in company and other
factors not available in all states just
had to let you know that so brian
Stelter thinks we're not talking about
russian collusion enough according to
News Buster's the media Research Center
did a study between June 1st and
September 30th Russia received more
airtime than any other topic on
mainstream news and guess how much of it
was slanted negatively toward president
Trump I'll give you a second to think of
it 97 percent 90 said it's not quite a
hundred I maybe I would have guessed a
hundred percent 97 percent is the number
of course they talk about Russia all the
time but they're desperate now to move
off of this issue of border security
because they're gonna lose that issue
and the Washington Post CNN can run as
many scare headlines as they want about
how President Trump is taking the blame
about how the border wall doesn't yet
have 50 percent approval it will have 50
percent approval if we keep focusing on
it if politicians keep focusing on it
and if the media keep focusing on it so
great keep keep it coming guys bring
give us more shutdown give us more
headlines about about the border wall
and border security the trouble with if
they pivot to Russia is there's not a
lot of there there and even ABC News is
admitting this what I'm getting is that
this is all building up to the Mullen
report and raising expectations of a
bombshell report and there been
expectations that have been building of
course for over a year on this but
people who are closest to what Muller
has been doing over interacted with the
Special Counsel cautioned me that this
report is almost certain to be
anti-climatic
that if you look at what the FBI was
investigating in that New York Times
report you look at what they were
investigating Muller did not go anywhere
with that investigation he has been
writing his report in real time through
these indictments and we have seen
nothing from Muller on the central
question of was there any coordination
collusion with the Russians in the
effort to meddle in the elections or was
there even any knowledge on the part of
the President or anybody in his camp aim
with what the Russians were definitely
that in the George Stephanopoulos the
former spokesman and communications
director for Bill Clinton you think well
then oh not yet not yet but maybe they
get mad Jonathan Karl is a very serious
journalist and by the way that wasn't a
clip from The Daily wire that wasn't a
clip from CR TV or the blaze TV that
wasn't a clip from Fox News it wasn't a
clip from any right-wing source that was
ABC with the former Clinton
communications director sitting there in
the anchor chair and they're saying that
sources are familiar with the Moller
investigation are pointing out there
isn't much
they are there with regard to Russian
collusion so you've got now these big
issues the two issues dominating the
news the Muller investigation and the
government's shut down / border wall and
everything you see in the headline says
this is really damaging to Republicans
and conservatives and Donald Trump when
you dig in just slightly below the
surface it doesn't really seem to be the
poll numbers seem to be in our favor and
everything we're hearing about the rush
investigation seems to be in our favor
as well bad news for Democrats
especially as they look toward 2020 and
I know I know you're gonna remember
where you were on Saturday afternoon I
know you probably came home you wrote it
in your diary I remember exactly where I
was when the future also ran who Leon
Castro admitted that he was going to
announce rather that he was going to run
for president and I I just I remember
where I was when a guy with the name of
Castro decided that he was going to win
the state of Florida when compressed at
Joe election here is his very very sad
presidential announcement
we're united by something bigger and in
this journey in the days to come
together we will show that hope can be
bigger than beer that light can be
bigger than darkness and that truth can
be bigger than lies and as long as we
work for it tomorrow
always be better than today so let's go
word bubble goes good is better than bad
forward is better than backward yummy is
better than icky on delay on delay
amigos give me a break what a pathetic
announcement that not a soul cared about
it does this guy stand a chance I know
we were saying that about Donald Trump
in 2015 2016 does Julian Castro stand a
chance he is on the one hand leaning in
to a Latino identity politics so he's
got a little accent over the a on his
logo he ended his announcement speech by
saying vamanos you know I don't know I
think he speaks English because he spoke
in English for the first part of the
speech and for some reason he ended it
in Spanish I couldn't quite tell you why
he is playing into this identity
politics but then his the entire stuff
of his announcement speech was just this
boiled over poor man's Barack Obama
platitudes I mean it was just nothing it
was all that sort of good is better than
bad hope is better than fear we're gonna
you know like okay we did that once we
we did that with the guy who's way
better at it than you
nobody wants a poor man's Barack Obama
you need to offer voters something so
who Leon Castro's announcement basically
I don't think changes the field I mean
he's running for vice president he's not
running for president right now is I
don't even know if he's showing up in
the polling in part that's because he
doesn't have a lot of name recognition
and also because he's just not that
impressive he was the Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development for a
minute and he was a mayor like okay all
right when is is the county executive
gonna run for president now to is the
dog catcher gonna it's really sad what
it shows us that the reason that his
announcement actually matters is it
shows us that everybody and his
grandmother is going to be running for
the not Democrat nomination for
president in 2020 and actually we had
another person that nobody expected
and nobody expects to become president
announced over the past week Democratic
Rep Tulsi Gabbard on CNN's banjo
the show are you gonna run for president
of the United States and do something
about it I think you should are you
think you sure I have decided to run and
we'll be making a formal announcement
within the next week whoa
what so you don't you actually I mean
obviously they set this up beforehand
but the way you can even hear it in the
audience's reaction Van Jones sets it up
he says well you're complaining about it
maybe you should run are you gonna run
for office and she sits there and she's
an you expect her to say oh I don't
think so not yet okay you're fine
because she's like nobody's ever heard
of her ever and then she says yes I am
going to run and you can almost hear the
gasps of surprise in the audience like
oh gosh now I guess I have to Google
this person to find out who she is
however saying all of that it doesn't
look like she's got a great shot she's a
congresswoman from Hawaii
I don't think Hawaii has ever given us a
president member of Congress congressmen
don't usually get elected president that
that all said she is a much more
interesting candidate than who Leon
Castro she she served in the Hawaii Army
National Guard so she's got military
experience she's held various positions
on different issues here eras on
same-sex marriage before it became
mandatory in the Democrat Party to
wholeheartedly embrace redefining
marriage she said quote to try to act as
if there's a difference between civil
unions and same-sex marriage is
dishonest cowardly and extremely
disrespectful to the people of Hawaii
who have already made overwhelmingly
clear our position on this issue as
Democrats we should be representing the
views of the people not a small number
of homosexual extremists so that was a
review not that long ago then all of a
sudden 2012 rolls around Obama endorses
gay marriage Joe Biden endorses
redefining marriage and all of a sudden
she turns around and says she endorses
it too this is going to come back to
bite her so she's got she checks off a
lot of the intersectionality boxes that
will help her in this inevitable race
politics primary she's the first Hindu
ever in Congress she's got religion
diversity going for her but they're
already slinging dirt on her that she's
homophobic this is already coming and
it's not coming from Republicans it's
coming from either Liz Warren or baito
Aurora core Kamala Harris or cory booker
blahblah any of the other thousand
democrats who are already in the race
this is going to be really ugly you see
this all around you see this actually in
oscars politics the as the award season
is coming to Hollywood all of a sudden
movies that everybody liked and thought
were really nice Green Book Bohemian
Rhapsody there was no controversy all of
a sudden now that they're winning Golden
Globes you're seeing smear campaigns
against them how they're awful they're
racist they're this they're that they're
sexist and you're and you're gonna see
the exact same thing in any competitive
campaign season and 2020 is certainly no
exception to that they're gonna get her
for being homophobic I don't know what
they're gonna get Julian Castro on yet
probably they won't need to get him on
anything because no one knows his name
but now Liz Warren is already stepping
in it too she was up in New Hampshire
and she was asked a question by a
wonderful troll of a reporter asking her
if she supports renaming Columbus Day
indigenous peoples day she should have
pretended not to hear the question and
moved on this is not a winning issue for
chiefly owatta and yet what does she say
she says my feeling is why would we not
want to honor indigenous people these
are the people who in Massachusetts
reached out and helped the first
settlers help them survive those first
harsh and rugged years I'm in favor of
honoring I think that's a good thing to
do to honor my people that you know she
didn't say that part a really bad issue
for her she is sort of a joke she's
being mocked by the reporters in front
of her this happened when she announced
that she was running she was mocked by a
reporter who said who what do you tell
to voters who like you in your policies
but think that your unelectable because
you're a fraud that she's being mocked
roundly I don't see this getting better
she's had years to come up with an
answer to these questions she hasn't so
she goes in week Castro goes in very
week Gabbard is going and week who are
the others Joe Biden Joe Biden's brother
says that he's definitely going to be
running everybody is running this time
but again what
he has a plagiarist who's run for
president multiple times now and lost he
he's kind of out of it he's going to be
very old if he's gonna be re-elected for
the first time who else Bernie Sanders
is a thousand years old
they're already accusing him of running
basically a bizarre sex ring on his
campaign you're seeing a lot of dirt
being slung at him from the meat to
movement who else bado is pretty green
they haven't figured out how to attack
him yet but I'm sure they will what this
all goes to show it gets back to our
first point we made in the show today
all of the headlines all of the generic
headlines seem to show that things are
going very poorly for the Republicans
and specifically for Donald Trump with
regard to the 2020 race a generic
Democrat almost certainly would defeat
President Trump in a 2020 election I'm
fairly confident of that if an if we got
generic Democrat Capital G capital D to
run for office on a ticket with generic
Democrat number two they probably would
beat Donald Trump in 2020 the problem is
there is no such thing as a generic
Democrat there's just no such thing so
can president Trump beat who Leon Castro
yeah yes he can can he beat Tulsi
Gabbard also certainly yes can he beat
Joe Biden a little tougher but yeah
probably can he beat bado O'Rourke
we'll have to see we don't know a ton
about if he's a good campaigner but I
think probably I don't really see bado
connecting in Pennsylvania I don't
really see bado connecting in Florida or
even Michigan I don't know so the
generic the generic news for Democrats
is great but you've got to get down at
the particulars we're gonna get into the
particulars in a little bit even with
regard to American history and the
Constitution on this day in history
we've also got it covered the new drag
kid that Democrats are pimping out and
needles at Starbucks but first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
I'm sorry if you're on daily wire.com
thank you you helped keep the lights on
you keep khofifah in our cups if you're
not it's 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
and replevin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you have to ask questions in the mailbag
ESS questions backstage you get to watch
another Kingdom you get everything most
importantly you get the leftist ears
tumblr this
is so important because the next time
that liz warren is having a beer on
camera with her husband and the next
time that the entire internet roundly
mocks her the next time she cracks open
that beer she's going to be drinking the
beer but she's going to be expelling
left his tears and you're gonna need
this leftist ears tumbler it's the only
fda-approved vessel for salty and
delicious leftist ears go to daily we're
calm we'll be right back with a lot more
alright one of the most disturbing
stories that I've seen in a long time is
the new drag kid I guess it's the most
disturbing story since the last story
about a drag kid this is parents putting
their little children 7 8 10 years old
children dressing the little boys up as
girls having them parade around for
lecherous men and do little dances this
happened with this kid
they call him desmond is amazing now
there's a new kid a 10 year old Canadian
boy Nima's Quinn Malan Sohn golden he
was featured in a very troubling piece
in Huck magazine it was just talking
about his life as a child drag queen and
it gets even creepier than some of the
other ones because he posed for a photo
with a drag queen named violet chachki
who is this guy who won season seven of
RuPaul's Drag Wiis drag race who in the
photo was naked so they they're now
pimping out this kid this ten-year-old
little kid who they dressing him up like
a girl and they're having him pose with
naked men for the amusement of their
sick and perverted audience this child's
parents should be in prison at the very
least they should be in prison the key
should be thrown away at the very least
this photographer Jonathan Frederick
terton should be in prison this is sick
pedophilia this is sick child abuse if
this were happening not on the pages of
glamorous leftist magazines but in a
housing project somewhere in the Bronx
that kid would be taken away from his
parents kids have been taken away from
their parents by the state for good
reason
for a hell of a lot less than putting
him out in sexualized women's clothing
and having him pose with naked men for
magazine photos this is sick sick
pedophilia and now there is a backlash
there's a backlash I see it on Twitter
you see it from the comment area all
over magazines and blogs they're saying
there's nothing inherently sexual about
drag queens
first of all yes there is yes there is
I'm from New York
I grew up in New York I've hung around
the village plenty of sea you know I've
gone by drag bars it is inherently
sexual because the idea of a drag queen
is a character a sexualized cartoonish a
idea of what of what a woman is and of
what femininity is it isn't simply
femininity you don't see child drag
queens wearing pantsuits like Hillary
Clinton they're wearing feathered boas
and they're wearing sequined dresses and
it is a sexualized act the other kid the
other drag kid whose parents are are
abusing him was recently found dancing
at a gay bar with men throwing dollar
bills at him but you're gonna tell me
that that's not sexualized of course it
is and you know what is certainly
sexualized putting that little kid in
women's clothing and having impose next
to a grown naked man who himself is
pretending to be a woman that is child
abuse and I know that we as
conservatives we often talk about the
overreaches of the government and the
overreaches of the government telling us
how to raise our kids how to come into
our kids lives and our families lives
this is an example of where the
government could come in and do a lot of
good that those kids should be removed
from their highly horribly abusive
parents their abusive parents should be
prosecuted should be convicted should at
least go to prison for a very long time
and these kids will have better lives
the one Desmond is amazing his abusive
parents said that when he was 2 or 3
years old he began to explore different
identities he's 2 or 3 years old he was
exploring the rug when he was crawling
around saying Google gaga
he wasn't exploring anything these sick
pedophile freaks are imposing this on
their children and ruining their lives
look children who put their kids into
show business generally are ruining
their lives because it's a really awful
industry you wouldn't put your kids in
the coal mines when they're 7 years old
and you probably shouldn't put them in
front of a camera either but even that
is is one thing even that can lead to a
career it usually is a destructive life
but that's one thing but to put your kid
in this sexualized sphere for the
edification
and the amusement and the pleasure of
sick pedophile men is rank abuse and
it's it's gonna ruin these kids lives
they never had the choice to decide that
they wanted to be drag queens at two
three four they don't have the choice to
do it at seven eight nine or ten either
it's a great irony of leftism right now
that we're told that consent is
everything we need informed consent
about everything if you're gonna kiss a
girl she's got to sign a notarized
contract in order to do it oh and also
dress up your eight year old kid who
obviously cannot give consent dress him
up in dresses and have perverted men
throw dollar bills at them at a bar
that's a good idea too it's this paradox
there are these contradictions within
leftism because a leftism does not have
any coherent philosophy it is an
ideology that is primarily attacking
tradition it is attacking our tradition
our civilization in the West broadly
we'll get to that a little bit later on
this day in history but and we should
never fail to point out when the Left
contradicts itself because it doesn't
care about logical coherence it doesn't
care about logical coherence and it
doesn't care about these little kids
lives it just cares about attacking
tradition and attacking big-daddy at the
top of the imaginary patriarchy that
that haunts their fever dreams really
disgusting stuff and I hope that
lawmakers are listening in Canada in the
United States and I hope law enforcement
is listening in Canada in the United
States and I hope you take these kids
out of their awful abusive environments
and I hope that youth throw these awful
parents in the clink and throw away the
key another terrible idea that's going
on right now in society is Starbucks
Starbucks now installing needle disposal
boxes and some of its bathrooms this is
after a 3,700 signature petition from
co-worker org you'll remember a little
while ago when Starbucks said that
everyone is welcome in the store you
don't need to buy a product you don't
need to be a customer if we don't let
vagabonds in to live here and do drugs
were racist somehow so shocked surprise
surprise it turns out that Starbucks is
turned into a homeless shelter and when
you go into the bathroom now the
employees have been stuck by needles
that have been left over
by drug addicts potentially exposing
them to hepatitis or HIV or anything
else so now these co-workers are saying
we don't want to step on needles while
we're doing our job at the coffee shop
figure out a way to stop this Starbucks
has two choices they can either kick out
vagabond drug addicts as they should or
they can install needle disposal cartons
in the bathrooms which is what it sounds
like they're going to do and and the
trouble is Starbucks because it's such a
prominent industry leader can set the
tone in other places can follow suit
this is broadly reflected in the in our
debate on criminal justice reform and I
know a lot of right-wingers are in
conflict on this question should we let
a lot of criminals out of prison is that
compassionate or should we not do that
should we try to lock up criminals and
be a little harsher on crime the answer
is be harsher on crime period there is
nothing compassionate nothing
compassionate about Starbucks allowing
drug-addled vagabonds to come in and
further damage their lives and further
inject poison in their veins and give
them incentives to do it by giving them
a place to dispose their needles there's
nothing compassionate about allowing
their employees to be possibly exposed
to HIV and other diseases just for
coming in and working at a coffee shop
there's nothing compassionate about
having customers who tend to be sort of
millennial yuppies just in their writing
the next great American novel or
something there's nothing a passionate
about having them in that disgusting
environment there's nothing right
there's nothing just there's nothing
moral about that throw these people
first of all throw them out of the
Starbucks shop but then broadly what do
you do is homeless populations increase
tent cities crop up all over Los Angeles
where I live and all over San Francisco
it's gotten so much worse their feces in
the street truly what is the solution
you can either give them incentives this
is why the left doesn't understand
economics so you've got to really make
it simple for them you can either give
them incentives not to do drugs and
defecate in the street or you can give
them incentives to do all of those
things if we took all of these people
and offer them a choice said you can
either go to a shelter where you can't
do drugs or you can go to prison
that would clear up the problem rudy
giuliani basically did that in the 90s
in New York and it turned New York into
Disneyland it turned a disgusting crime
ridden city into a relatively quite nice
place to live
throw them in prison if you throw them
in prison they will sober up I promise
you this question a debate constantly
among conservatives is is the drug war a
good thing or a bad thing and you see
the kind of divisions among conservative
thought which I celebrate it's a good
thing that we have intellectual
diversity on the right the left
certainly doesn't have it but the drug
war is a good thing it's a necessary
thing we it's not the ideal of the
libertarian stateless society or
whatever fantasies are are put forward
by political theorists but we are in the
midst of a horrific opioid epidemic we
see that policies where we encourage
people to have new needles and live on
the street and defecate wherever they
want do not help the problem they
exacerbate the problem the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and it's
it's a moral confusion that we're
suffering from that we only see this a
very narrow perverse idea of compassion
and we're not realizing the awful damage
that we're doing to society broadly I've
also got to talk about this day in
history speaking of the road to Hell
being paved with good intentions because
this day in history to this day is in
history on this day in history in 1942
Japanese internment policy went into
effect this was from Franklin Roosevelt
this came through Proclamation number 25
37 and it's sort of misunderstood the
way that Japanese internment first
worked is that all foreign aliens
illegal aliens or resident aliens from
the axis nations Germany Italy in Japan
had to register with the US Department
of Justice following this there was the
alien Registration Act of 1940 then
finally in 42 there was the executive
order 9066 which authorized the physical
removal of all japanese-americans even
if you had as little as 1/16 Japanese
ancestry you could be physically
forcibly moved into an internment camp
the reason I bring this up is because
it's not brought up
very much in American politics and the
reason it's not brought up very much is
it doesn't look very good for
progressives and Democrats so every
crime committed by anyone who could
vaguely be called conservative is
constantly rehashed dating all the way
back to the Crusades we constantly hear
about that you don't hear terribly much
about Japanese internment and the reason
is this when conservatives and
Republicans point out that Democrats
have an awful history a party history of
misery from slavery to Jim Crow to
disfranchising people to lynchings on
and on and on they say well that was
before the parties switched those guys
were they were conservative Democrats
they weren't progressive Democrats and
it's blahblahblah and they sort of get
away with this silly argument you can't
get away with that with Franklin
Roosevelt Franklin Roosevelt invented
our welfare state Frank if Franklin
Roosevelt wasn't a progressive who was a
progressive Franklin Roosevelt is one of
the presidents that Democrats and
progressives hold up is one of the
Great's in history him and Woodrow
Wilson and Lyndon Johnson those are the
three big ones for progressives but
Franklin Roosevelt is the one who issued
Japanese internment this is historically
a big problem for Democrats they can't
get around it we should point it out
because the logical conclusion of
leftist big government socialist
governments taking over the industries
the logical conclusion of that is that
they can control you they can move you
they can take your property they can
take your livelihood they can take where
you live and move it to someplace else
I've been writing a lot about Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes and the dangers posed by
socialism and you always hear oh well
socialism it's fine stop demagoguing so
what's the big deal
you get free health care as Ronald
Reagan pointed out the government big
enough to give you everything that you
have is everything that you want rather
is big enough to take away everything
that you have and nowhere do you see
that more clearly than in the leftist
progressive legacy of Franklin Roosevelt
we also have to talk about speaking of
political philosophy
on this day in history in 1639 the first
constitution in any American colony came
to be the Fundamental Orders in Hartford
Connecticut and this was a binding
compact it was a frame of government the
reason that I bring up this obscure
colony Constitution is because it really
shows us an important aspect of what we
conservatives should think about when we
frame our political philosophy with
regard to modern politics I think
conservatives talk too much about the
Constitution I do I know that will sound
controversial
I love the Constitution I think it's one
of the greatest documents ever written I
can't love it enough however I think we
we fall into this trap as conservatives
of only focusing on this one document on
the Constitution we say it's written in
the Constitution therefore that's that's
the be-all and end-all that's the
beginning in the end of the country and
it we have to follow it and if we don't
follow it we've gone terribly wrong and
why aren't people following it and come
on guys don't you remain it's right
there right none that why aren't you
doing it and we get very frustrated by
this because at least half of our
country broadly just regards the
Constitution regularly the Constitution
is not the beginning of our country it's
not even the first constitution in the
history of our country that's the
beautiful thing about our country and
that view is the essence of conservative
thought our country didn't spring into
being magically in 1776 or 1789 or 1787
or 1791 it doesn't or the 1800 present
it doesn't it happens organically it
happened through evolution not just
revolution and even the American
Revolution was a fairly conservative
revolution we kept so much from the
English system of government we got rid
of the King we booted him out but we
kept so much and that Society had been
built organically not just since 1775
but since 1620 since the pilgrims
arrived on the Mayflower since more
settlers arrived in the new world since
more Englishmen arrived in the new world
and created colonies and formed colonies
in those colonies worked with each other
variously and ultimately came together
not because of the proclamation of some
rationalist theorists it
an ivory tower somewhere but through the
people of those colonies and their
representatives working together to form
and fight for specific goals to form
together to fight the French and Indian
War to come together to fight certain
onerous taxes passed by the Parliament
in King George to fight certain onerous
regulations that they didn't like it
came together through evolution not
revolution this is the heart of what
Edmund Burke talks about and well
Russell Kirk talks about and what the
conservative tradition in the post-war
conservative movement really talks about
I put up question up on Twitter last
week and I said if you were a concern it
for all the Conservatives how would you
best describe your views and I gave a
few options obviously there are a lot of
others I said would you say you're
traditionalist you're a libertarian or
classical liberal you're a
neoconservative or you're on the
religious right and I think broadly that
those four categories describe the
different types of conservative out
there today and by far people said
classical liberal or libertarian and
traditionalists came in a little a
little smaller I think we've got to
recover some of that because that is the
essence of conservatism we're conserving
something and we're not just old fogies
we're talking about a tradition which is
actually not the the old thing it's the
newest thing we have because it's
endured throughout the ages it transmits
wisdom from our earliest ancestors in
ancient Greece it trans transports
wisdom from throughout the ages that we
can still access which by trial and
error has been helpful to us and which
by prescription we can possibly
understand in the future you know that
the two virtues which I think define the
conservative / the leftist are prudence
and humility prudence which we get from
ancient Greece which we get from
Aristotle being being wise in our
judgment taking care of whole contexts
and saying well we should maybe be a
little cautious here this is a good okay
this is why being prudent and then
humility which is an innovation of
Christianity
obviously conservatives are much more
humble than leftists we don't think
we're going to come
strucked the utopian society we don't
think that our ideas are the only ideas
in the whole wide world
we don't insist that everyone chose the
party line or if they don't we're gonna
shut them up it's kind of funny to brag
about how humble you are it sort of
undercuts your argument but the
Conservatives just demonstrably are much
more humble and when we have a humility
because the beginning of wisdom is is
fear of the Lord is an awe and is a
wonder and as a humility when we have a
humility not just to the other people
living today but to the democracy of the
Dead to our forefathers to the the
people that we should be grateful for
for forging our country not in one's big
moment but over generations and
generations and generations that gives
you an historical wisdom that will not
just let you look back in history but
will allow you to look forward with a
little bit of prescription and a little
bit of wisdom to see how we should craft
our country in the future all right
that's our show we ran out of time we
got a lot more to get to though so we'll
do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael nose this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michaels show is produced by Robert
Sterling executive producer Jeremy Moore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico audio is
mixed by Dylan case production assistant
Nick shyam hair and makeup is by Jesuit
Vera the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19